hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
multiplexing on mouse tissue using cell
signaling technology antibodies
and opal ihg method i am christy joel of
labrutz
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored
by akoya biosciences and cell signaling
technology
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you like
at any time you like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box
and click send if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
you can use your ask a question box to
let us know you're experiencing a
problem
additionally this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits
after viewing the presentation just
click on the continuing education
credits tab
and follow the process to obtain your
credits i would now like to introduce
our speakers
bill kennedy reagent specialists at aqua
biosciences
and chris grange ihc specialist at cell
signaling technology
for complete biographies on our speakers
please visit our biography tab
at the top of your screen bill and chris
you may now begin
your presentations
um thanks for the introduction christy
uh hi my name is bill kennedy and i'm
the reagent sales specialist for koi
biosciences
in the northeast and midwest today i'm
going to talk about using the opal
method of multiplex immunohistochemistry
in mouse tissue
now we all know that the tumor
microenvironment is very complex and we
try to understand the biology
but traditionally we've been probing
this complex system with one or two
dimensional techniques
mainly chromogenic ihc with dab
obviously immunohistochemistry has been
and is a vital tool in immuno-oncology
and holds an important place in any
anatomical pathology lab
but while other clinical labs
are using tests that are automated and
performed by calibrated instruments to
reduce
human error the majority of anatomical
pathology is still based on physician
interpretation
dab has been the gold standard but the
results are subjective
other methodologies provide quantitative
results but with a loss of morphological
context
so at the end results are compromised
multiplex immunohistochemistry allows us
to visualize up to eight biomarkers in a
single paraffin section
enabling phenotyping and quantitative
analysis
akoya's workflow which we call finoptic
supports multiplex ihc from staining to
imaging and analysis
pinoptix enables you to see your
biomarkers in morphological context
phenotype cells and assess spatial
relationships of cells
and one other thing that's really
important that phenotype synoptics
allows you to do
is isolate and remove autofluorescence
we'll talk about that a little bit more
in this presentation
synoptics is comprised of three
different tools
we have the detection reagents which
include
opal dyes eight of them the
multi-spectral imaging
systems including the vector polaris
and the powerful image analysis tool in
form software
today we're going to focus mainly on
multiplex ihc staining
now before we do that we're going to
talk a little bit about how
iht has been traditionally done to do
multiplex ihd in the past there were a
couple of options
you could use directly conjugated
primary antibodies but without signal
amplification
often the signals are very weak the
other option that you have is to use
secondary label fluorophores
with this method you can amplify the
signal somewhat but you have to be
to carefully select the species of both
the primary and secondary antibody
to avoid cross reactivity
if you have three markers they must be
from three different species
and that limits you to maybe three maybe
four colors
if you have weak signals that leads to
long exposure times
and then that leads to photo bleaching
and then there's always the problem of
autofluorescence and especially in
formal and fixed paraffin embedded
tissue
opal multiplex ihc is different opal
allows you to do up to eight biomarkers
on a section
it's compatible with any primary
antibody regardless of species
as long as you have a secondary hrp for
your primary antibody
you can use it with opal and you don't
have to worry about cross reactivity
because after we do one round of opal
staining we strip those antibodies
so what is opal many of you have
probably heard of jeremiah's signal
amplification
or have used it in the past termite
signal amplification
technology has been around for 30 years
and has been used in thousands of
publications
tsa uses hrp to amplify the signal and
covalently bind to the epitope
this covalent binding is what allows us
to stain strip and then stain for the
next antibody
without fear of cross reactivity
now what does the opal workflow look
like um the workflow is sequential and
it looks
very similar to the staining that most
labs are currently doing
you de-paraffinize your slides do your
antigen retrieval
do your blocking step add your primary
antibody
your secondary hrp it's very important
that it's labeled with horseradish
peroxidase
and then you add your opal tsa
fluorophore
at that point the opal tsa floor is
covalently bound to the epitope
and now we can add heat to strip
once the stripping is completed we can
repeat that process
and start for the next antibody we can
do that up to eight times
and then add dappy and mount
so here's a little cartoon that
demonstrates a typical opal stain
the first primary secondary hrp and opal
fluid are added
opal binds to the epitope and then heat
is added
now we're ready to add our next second
antibody
the second antibody and detection are
added and this process is repeated to
stand up to eight biomarkers on a single
section
with opal we get some really beautiful
stains and here's an example of a six
flex
seven color stain imaged on the vector
polaris
we also have the ability to do a nine
color stain with eight antibodies
and this was also imaged on the vector
polaris
now let's talk about opal kits opal kits
contain all of the reagents that you
need for detection and come
in multiple kit formats
we have a four color kit and a seven
color kit
both of these are available for manual
or automated staining
um we've also recently released
a pd1 pdl panel kit for both lung and
melanoma
these kits have been optimized by akoya
and are ready to use on the bond system
we've done the work for you so you don't
have to and
what we're going to focus on today is
the opal mouse kit
and the opel mouse kit comes with this
anti-rabbit hrp secondary and
that's what we'll use with our cst
antibodies
of course we have manual kits but we
also have automated kits that can be
used on the leica bond rx in the roche
discovery ultra
now on to the mouse staining in our lab
we did a six flex
stain plus dappy on most tissue and we
used most breast cancer tumors
it was fully automated on the bond
using six antibodies from cell signaling
technology
five of the six antibodies were rabbit
monoclonals with the exception of one
cytokeratin which was a biotinylated
mouse monoclonal
the six antibodies that were used were
fox p3
cytokeratin cd31
cd4 cd8
and f480 for macropages
we use the opal four color rabbit kit
and we had it added three additional
fluorophores to make a seven color assay
this this kit was designed for those
rabbit antibodies in mouse tissue and
contains everything that we need to do
the stain contains
all of the detection reagents and then
like i said we
we added those three opal fluorophores
on top of what came in the kit
and here are the antibody fluorophore
pairings
as well as the order that they were done
in
these slides were image on the vector
polaris and here are the results
this first image is from a mouse spleen
which stains nicely for five markers but
there's no cytokeratin in most planes so
it's not here this was a really nice
control but when we moved it to
the most breast cancer these were the
images that you get
here are our six markers plus dappy
and those are separated by channel
if we look at another image we can see
all six markers plus dappy
there's nice staining but in most of
these samples cytokeratin was ubiquitous
in these sections
so at some points it made it hard to
read so all we have to do
is turn off one of the channels so we
turn off the cytokeratin channel
if we turn off the cytokeratic channel
we see some really beautiful staining of
five biomarkers plus dappy
opal works really nicely with mouse
tissue
i just want to touch on the imaging
portion for a minute
all of these slides were imaged on the
vector polaris
the polaris performs whole slide seven
color multi-spectral imaging
as well as nine color field of view
what makes the player special is that it
uses multi-spectral imaging technology
which just allows us to unmix and
separate colors
as well as remove autofluorescence
and to give you an example of that this
image
shows pancreas mixed and
with autofluorescence
if we unmix we isolate and remove the
autofluorescence giving us this image so
you can see this is very powerful
and will help you have confidence in
your data
so in conclusion seven color opal
multiplex ihc is robust and reproducible
on mouse tissue
and expands the tools available to
researchers
um using well-validated antibodies is
important and that's why we use cell
signaling
antibodies now i'm going to pass this
over to chris grange from cst
thank you very much bill this is chris
grange here from
signaling technology and i'm happy to be
here today to
talk with you about the crucial need for
antibody specificity
in multiplex panels
as singleplex assays evolve into more
complex multiplex assays
high quality validation has never been
more important than it is today
multiplex assays can offer tremendous
benefit such as maximal data per tissue
section
which can be critical when working with
limited human tissue samples
they also allow for the understanding of
co-expression and spatial organization
of multiple targets and formal and fixed
paraffin and
embedded tissues in the field of immuno
oncology
and can expand the understanding of the
tumor microenvironment
in this setting it becomes crucial that
highly malignated antibodies are
utilized
in traditional singleplex chromogenic
ihc that is not often quantified
it is possible for researchers to work
around or ignore some non-specific
signal
in the multiplex setting combining
multiple sub-optimal antibodies
can significantly confound results for
these reasons
we recommend that researchers choose
antibodies for use in multiplex assays
that have been highly validated and
demonstrate significant
specific signal in ffpe tissues
without rigorous validation in the
singleplex setting it would be
impossible to
determine if all the antibodies featured
in this multiplex image of an ll2
cintgenetic tumor
are staining specifically
today's talk will cover some principles
of ihc validation that we use here at
cst
what i like to call our ihc validation
toolbox
in which i'll give some examples of the
tools that we use in our work i'll tell
a
short story about pdl1 species
reactivity testing
and then i'll summarize our findings
from today
in its most basic form iit validation
can be broken down into two simple
questions
does the antibody stain where it is
supposed to and is there no stain where
no expression is expected if it can be
explained so simply then why is ic
validation so difficult
two confounding factors are the biology
of the targets and the abundance of
different cell types and tissues
for many targets the biology is poorly
understood and the expression pattern is
mostly unknown
with so many different cell types
present in each ffpe tissue section
it can often be nearly impossible to
determine where staining should be
present for more complex targets
it is important to note that the level
and type of iht validation differs for
each target
here we see a couple examples of targets
with well-defined biology
on the top is an antibody directed
against against gfap
whose expression is combined to the
brain and peripheral nerves
as you can see there is nice signal in
the brain sections
along with a peripheral nerve of the
colon in other tissues
such as liver and prostate no signal is
present as expected
on the bottom is an antibody against
pmel which is a melanoma specific
antigen
we see nice signal in the melanoma cells
in the images on the left
and no staining in the other images of
various tumor types as expected
while targets such as these are
relatively straightforward the majority
of our validation
occurs on more difficult targets
what makes some targets more challenging
than others
well for some novel targets there is
little to no biological data available
in these cases the literature can tell
us very little about what cells and
tissues we should expect to be positive
conversely some well-studied targets can
also be challenging to validate in ifc
as the available literature can be
questionable or even conflicting
i'd like to note that when reviewing ihe
data in the literature
it must be evaluated critically in
instances where strong evidence is not
demonstrated for the specificity
of the antibodies used for these
difficult targets
an increased variety of validation
techniques are typically required
one must perform what is scientifically
necessary to gain confidence in
specificity
to that end we have mostly standardized
our initial validation strategy
we often start validation with cell
pallet models
we generally identify many clones that
stain as expected on cell pallet models
but eventually fail on tissue models
this again highlights the importance of
performing multiple assays
and using the appropriate tools to
identify highly specific antibodies for
ihc
testing then moves on to one or a small
number of
tissues with either high low or no
expression expected
if the observed staining seems
appropriate antibodies are assessed on
multiple tissue types
which is facilitated by the use of
tissue microarrays
from this point we have a number of
tools to further characterize
antibody performance in ffbe tissues as
i mentioned before
we must do what is scientifically
scientifically required to gain
confidence in specificity
note the following statement no single
assay is sufficient to verify
specificity of staining
it is not enough that the antibody
performs well in one experiment
or on one high low knockout cell model
or on one positive negative tissue model
it is the use of multiple assays and
strategies that helps build the case for
specificity
i will go through a few examples of the
strategies listed here
as i mentioned before we often start
with an ffpe cell pellet model
these cell pellets are fixed processed
and embedded just like tissue samples
cell pallets can serve as a useful first
step in validation
as they provide a system with known
protein expression
in this example you can see that this
clone performs well by isc
and western block on cell lines of known
positive and negative cd151 expression
this is an example of testing cross
reactivity of an antibody against its
related family members
such testing is performed for protein
targets that share high sequence
homology with other proteins
in this case using cell lines
transfected with related family members
egfr
her2 and her4 we can show that the
anti-her3 antibody detects just the her3
protein
and does not cross react with other
receptor tyrosine kinase family members
next i'll discuss the use of high and
low tissue models in ihd validation
here is a simple example of an antibody
that detects smooth muscle acting
in this section of mouse heart you can
see that the antibody is staining the
vascular smooth muscle as expected
while it is clean in the cardiomyocytes
this is
a good example of how we can use
negative internal controls
in this case the cardiac muscle cells to
guide our validation
here you can see how we are able to
leverage publicly available rna
expression data
in the human protein alice to aid in
validation
in this example staining of cd39
correlates well with the high
low and very low tissues predicted by
rna
per the human protein atlas some other
resources that can provide useful target
information
are phosphocyte biogps and unipro
as we have an increased focus in making
most reactive antibodies that work in
ihc
we have generated a number of rodent
models to aid in the validation of these
targets
as with human antibodies we will test
the most reactive antibodies
on various normal mouse tissues and
cinginae tumor models
in the examples here you can see that we
were able to modulate protein expression
using treatments as you can see
phosphos6
expression was inhibited upon rapamycin
treatment
next i'll briefly discuss how orthogonal
or non-antibody based assays
can be used in ihc validation examples
of orthogonal assays are mass
spectrometry
and rna scope
here you can see mass fat data that was
performed on a cohort of lung cancers
as you can see staining with an antibody
directed against dll3
correlates nicely with the protein
expression levels detected by mass spec
giving us increased confidence in the
specificity of the antibody
performance staining with antibodies
directed against two different epitopes
is one of the best validation tools we
have here at cst
in the case of notch 2 we expect to see
membrane staining
along with some nuclear signal
representative of active notch
but how can we be certain that the
distribution and level of nuclear
staining
is appropriate
fortunately we were able to develop
another clone that is directed against a
different portion of the protein
also with the within the intracellular
domain
since both antibodies detect independent
unique epitopes on human notch 2
and they show a similar staining pattern
on multiple tissues and cell types
we can have increased confidence in the
specificity of all of the staining
observed
confirmation of species reactivity is
important to include
if an antibody is predicted to react in
additional species
two shmt2 antibodies were developed that
show nice staining in hume
in multiple human tissues the staining
is mitochondrial as expected
and since the antibodies are directed at
different portions of the shmt2 protein
we can have confidence in these
antibodies on human models
both antibodies are predicted to react
with mouse based on western blot testing
and high secret homology with the mouse
shmt2 protein
as you can see the antibody on the top
shows nuclear signal and a subset of
immune cells
while on the bottom diffuse cytoplasmic
signal can be observed in pancreatic
acinar cells
note that both antibodies did not show
similar non-specificity issues
in human tissues it appears to be a
mouse species specific issue
and therefore these antibodies are not
suitable for mouse staining
now i'd like to briefly discuss some
species specific testing
that we did with a couple of our pdl1
antibodies
we recently heard from a customer that
our human reactive pdl1 clone
catalog number 13684 was working well
for them
in most tissues
while a blast of the antigenic sequence
of 13684 returned only a 56
homology with the mouse protein we
proceeded with the testing to compare
our mouse and human reactive products
the first step was to compare the two
antibodies on cells transfected with the
mouse pdl1 protein
as you can see both antibodies are able
to detect the over expressed pdl one
though the signal intensity of one three
six eight four
which is on the top is clearly weaker
as we move to tissue testing more
differences emerged
both antibodies seem to detect different
subsets of immune cells in the mouse
sinus
we can hypothesize that number 64988
on the bottom is more likely to be
correct
based on the stronger signal in the
transfected cells
but more testing is required
on ascend genetic tumor is where major
differences emerged
as you can see the mouse reactive colon
pictured on the bottom
is detecting scattered immune cells in
the tumor as expected
the human reactive clone on the top does
not appear to be detecting those cells
and also shows obvious non-specific
signal
in the rank of tumor cells and adjacent
muscle
if we had only tested one model such as
the transfected cells
or perhaps the thymus we might be
convinced that number 13684 is suitable
for use in mouse tissues
testing on multiple models and utilizing
a comparison antibody
were helpful tools in this situation
without the rigorous validation i
discussed here today we would not be
able to have confidence in the staining
we observed in a multiplex iht setting
as i mentioned earlier there is no way
to determine if the staining of these
most reactive panels
is specific without first validating
each antibody in a singleplex setting
using the tools discussed here today
so in summary iec validation should
always be tailored to each target
and various validation tools should be
employed
no one assay is ever sufficient multiple
assays synergistically combined to
demonstrate specificity
highly validated antibodies are crucial
in multiplex assays to produce reliable
staining results
thus enabling the researcher to make
discoveries with confidence
i'd like to thank everyone for their
time today and now we would like to open
it up to live questions
thank you
thank you chris and thank you bill for
your informative presentations
we will now start our live q a portion
of the webinar
now to our audience if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for okay
let's get started um bill let's start
with you
can i use a rat primary or other species
than rat antibodies on mouse tissue
that's a good question and the answer is
yes you can
definitely use a rat primary and as a
matter of fact you can use
any primary antibody regardless of the
species
as long as you have a secondary hrp
um against that primary species then it
will work with opal
so the answer is yes
thank you now chris let's pop over to
you i believe this one's for you how can
i avoid mouth on mouse reactivity
when multiplexing in mouse tissues and
tumors
uh christie for this one um
the easiest way to avoid muscle most
reactivity when
doing ihc in mouse tissues would be to
use
rabbit monoclonal antibodies all of the
antibodies we displayed in the talk
today were raised
in rabbit and for this reason they're
they're great choices for use
in most tissues um if you
are required to use a mouse monoclonal
anybody in mouse tissues
uh for example if there's not a good
rabbit monoclonal available
there are some commercially available
mouse on mouse reactivity kits
that could possibly be used to limit
mouse on mouse reactivity thanks chris
so let's pop back to you i have an
antibody that works
well with mouse tissue i'm sorry
i have an antibody that works well in
mouth tissue with dab
will it work with opal and what
adjustments
do you recommend
so generally if you have a mouse an
antibody that works well in mouse tissue
with dab then it's most likely going to
work well with opal
so generally we recommend trying it with
the same conditions that you have
that you've been using with the ab
you may find you have to dilute it two
to four times or even higher though
all right thank you we have some great
questions
coming in let's go let's
let's see let's go with this question
here
um what characteristics should i look
for when selecting an
antibody for use in a multiplex panel
the simplest answer would be to look for
high quality validation data so
if it were me i would look for companies
that display high quality images on the
web
and that show some of the tools that i
discussed here today
i guess the first place to start would
be to look for if the company selling
the antibody
recommends it for use in ihc in paraffin
embedded tissues
however that doesn't necessarily mean
it's going to be specific
some companies will display data that
was generated by customers
uh but here at cst all of the data and
images
we display on the product pages for a
given anybody
were all generated here in-house so that
should give
our customers more confidence in the
performance of our ic validated
antibodies
thanks chris is it possible to
quantify images using some machine
learning approaches
well that's a good question and with
multi-spectral imaging you're able to
quantify your images and we do that with
okoye's inform software which is some
powerful
software that will allow you to
quantify your images
thank you bill our next question
we have so many questions coming in
looking for some duplicates here
um let's go with
um here we go well all antibodies
approved for use in ihc work with the
akoya opal
reagents
christie the simple answer to that one
is yes
if anybody is well validated in ihc
using singleplex
chromogenic staining then there is a
very very high likelihood that it will
work well
uh with the opal immunofluorescent
reagents one thing to note though is
that
for example um cst at cst we have
recommended protocols for use in the
chromogenic setting
where we tell customers the optimal
dilution
when you switch over to using opal
reagents there's a chance that that
optimal dilution may change and
therefore
researchers may have to do some uh
additional
optimization work in that setting
thanks chris bill i believe this one's
for you i don't have a bond or ultra
can i do this manually
absolutely you know in the past few
years everybody's a lot of people have
been moving to automation but we still
have a lot of
customers who are doing manual staining
and
as long as you have a microwave oven to
do your antigen retrieval and stripping
you can do your staining manually
thanks bill can i use the same primary
antibody dilution with chromogenic and
fluorescent detection reagents
chris this might be for you i'm sorry
what was that
i have no problem can i use the same
primary antibiotic dilution
with chromogenic and fluorescent
detection reagents
oh right uh as i mentioned in the
previous question
um there's a chance that you might be
able to use the same primary antibody
dilution that we recommend
for chromogenic ihd but more likely than
not
because of the different sensitivities
and signal intensities
between chromogenic detection and the
tsa based detection with the opal kits
uh you'll likely have to use a different
uh primary antibody
solution and chris can you comment on
using polyclonal primary antibodies
grab it etc
yes of course there's no reason you
wouldn't be able to use
rabbit or mouse polychonal antibodies
with
the opal kits however generally speaking
using monoclonal antibodies whether it's
rabbit or mouse
leads to more consistent signal
and consistent performance from lot to
lot
and in an assay that complex
as a seven or eight color
uh opal
oval kit staining then
what we want to focus on is antibody
consistency
so for that reason we don't recommend
using
polyclonal antibodies however if it's
the only option available then it's
something that can be considered
thank you chris bill are your multiplex
kits limited to seven targets
you mentioned using nine opals how is
the spectra on mixing
so that's a good question so in my
presentation i talked about
doing six mark biomarkers plus dappy
recently about a little over a year ago
we came out with two new opal dies so
that allows us to do eight biomarkers
plus dappy
on the vector polaris
we have two there's two options you can
do whole slide seven color staining
um and then you can also do field of
view nine color staining
thank you our next question
um so let's come back to you your
presentation talks about
a seven color stain but i only want to
do
three or four markers is that possible
absolutely um so yeah generally um what
i what i showed
here today was that seven color um we do
sell kits that
um stain for four colors so that's
absolutely doable
and it's in to be honest it's a good way
to start
staining for opal start start low and
then increase as you go on
thank you now what was used on the
cytokeratin c11 clone as far as
mlm
as bill mentioned that clone is
biotinylated
so there was no reason to we didn't have
to detect it with
anti-mouse hrp so that's how we avoided
any mouse on mouse cross reactivity in
that setting
using just an unconjugated mouse
monoclonal primary antibody
you would run into issues with uh
secondary detection and mouse on mouse
reactivity
got it thank you
how would i get the protocols for using
multiple opal dyes on
same species antibodies
we have on opals akoya i mean on
koibaio.com
under resources we have a protocols page
where we have a couple of different
protocols for
seven color stains one one being a mouse
protocol
and then i can also share
my protocol as well
okay good thank you bill okay
our next question and again bear with me
we've got so many great questions coming
in and i want to make sure that
i answer once that everyone is asking um
how about this one is cst
developing validated antibodies for
brain cell markers
neuronal astrocytic and microglial
markers
uh yes we are we have a whole
development team here at cst
focused on neuronal markers and just
recently we've come out with
a few new products that are recommended
for use
in ic and paraffin embedded tissues
uh they include an iba one or a couple
iba one
antibodies which are used to detect uh
microglia
in the brain um aside from that i would
suggest visiting
the cst website to see what we have as
far as new
neuronal markers and customers can
always contact us via tech support with
any
specific questions about new products or
what we may have coming soon in the
pipeline
excellent thank you our next question uh
do you purchase opal die kits directly
from
okoya yes um all of the opal dyes
are sold by a koi and you can purchase
directly through us
very good thank you um
let's see how easy to optimize
or let me rephrase this how easy is it
to optimize the new antibody for a new
antigen that replaces
one of your standard protocols
i know we have so many questions coming
in i can repeat that if necessary
uh please sorry about that no problem
how easy is it to optimize a new
antibody for a new antigen
that would replace one of your standard
protocols
i think this question is referring to a
situation where
you would have an optimized
opal panel and you want to substitute
a new antibody for one that's been
previously optimized in the panel
in that case it can be
it's not necessarily just that you plug
in the new antibody
but my suggestion would be to test the
new antibody
in the panel where you plan in the order
you plan to place it
and then if those results are
satisfactory then great if not then
the panel will likely likely require a
bit more optimization and possibly
changing the order of staining
and which opal fluorophores are used for
each
antibody thank you now when
troubleshooting with oval reagents
would you recommend diluting opal ab
colors if you are getting a lot of
background
um so that's a good question so there's
a couple of levers you can change when
optimizing an opal stain the first is
your primary antibody if you're getting
background then
it's probably your primary antibody that
needs to be diluted out further
if you're seeing your signal intensities
too high then you it would dilute your
opal dies
thank you our next question
uh does cst have a good anti-mouse pan
ck
antibody preferably not raised in mouth
um the the only option we have right now
for a pan cytokeratin antibody
is the one that bill spoke about in the
panel
during this presentation um as we
mentioned
the particular variant he used
is conjugated to biotin
which helps us reduce or helps us avoid
any muscle
mouse cross reactivity um we don't
currently have
a rabbit monoclonal uh that detects
pan cytokeratin in ffpe tissues
at this time
okay our next question i have an
antibody that does not work
well with dab but has been shown to work
with directly conjugated secondary fl
antibodies will it work with opal
yeah so um in this instance you know i
guess when i see that
it's working with the secondary
fluorescent antibody
i'm surprised that it's not working with
dab but that being said
um since it's working with your
secondary conjugate
since opal is actually amplifying it
even more than your secondary conjugate
um then then you should be able to get
amplification of that antibody
and so it should work with opal
very good thank you let's see
uh let's go with our next question
let's go here
yes let's take this question can i use
an antibody created in a species
other than mouth or rabbit for example
rat
uh yes you can uh basically with the
opal
technology and the opal kits you can use
an anybody
that was raised in any species
the limiting factor would be having an
hrp conjugated secondary antibody
that detects uh in anybody raised in
your
in your species of interest so if you
had anybody raised in for instance
something like a chicken you would need
an hrp
conjugated anti-chicken secondary
uh in order to use that antibody in the
the opal kits and in the multiplex
setting but
the simple answer is yes as long as you
have an hrp
conjugated secondary antibody to detect
your primary antibody
then you can use antibodies raised in
any different species
that you would like thanks chris
uh bill can multiplex opal dies be
visualized on
standard confocal microscope or a vectra
and mantra system
are or are the vector and matrix system
necessary
um yeah so the answer is yes it can be
visualized on the standard
confocal microscope or even your
standard fluorescent microscope you know
as long as you have the correct laser
lines or filter sets in place
you'll be able to use opal the vector
and mantra
are nice to have because if you want to
move beyond those three or four colors
where you're getting
um spectral overlap um then then
if you want to get to those seven or
eight colors then you most likely would
need
a multi-spectral instrument like the
vectra or
mantra thank you
and try to reword this question does the
opal technology permit
to detect intracellular targets
uh yes just like in standard
singleplex chromogenic ihc on ffpe
tissues
the oval kit can detect proteins that
are expressed
on the membrane in the cytoplasm and in
the nucleus
so it doesn't necessarily matter where
your protein
is expressed you can easily detect it
with both chromogenic ihc
and the opal technology
thank you and chris both your talks you
and bill both focus on antibody
specificity for ffpe
tissues what about fresh frozen
tissues how do antibodies develop for
ffpe tissues
generally perform on fresh frozen
tissues
yeah this is a good question we have
found
that generally if an antibody works on
ffpe tissues
it is very likely to work in fresh
frozen tissues
it may require a bit of additional
optimization to get your protocol right
but for the most part if it works in ffv
tissues it's likely to work in fresh
frozen tissues
now i will say it doesn't necessarily
work the other way around
right so if an antibody works in frozen
tissues
there's definitely some uncertainty
about whether it would work in ffbe
tissues
my recommendation would be that if you
have an antibody that you know works in
fresh frozen tissues
you would need to do some pretty high
level validation work
in ffpe tissues before you were
confident
that it's uh staining specifically
in formula and fixed tissues
thank you chris look and we have time
for a few more questions but i want to
remind our audience
that those questions that we are unable
to answer today because we have a lot of
questions coming in
and additionally those questions that
come in during the on-demand period
those will be answered via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration
okay let's do a few more questions um
[Music]
bill over to you could you share some of
your validation
data for your opal detection and its
heat application that strips prior
antibody complexes
um so basically uh are we we're asking
for a protocol here
um yeah we can uh we can share some of
that
okay great we have their email address
okay and
bill let's um stick with you can you
please clarify
the specific protocol differences
between hand staining and automated
staining
using your platform
yeah um so there the um
obviously it's a little bit different
putting slides on the bond or the
ultra the discovery ultra the main
differences being
um the heating steps and so with
manual staining you're using the
microwave um and
with the bond and the ultra you're not
you're just using
you're just using heat so there's little
differences there
um the protocol time
to do it on the bond or the ultra is
just basically an overnight state
it's an overnight run whereas the
doing it manually just takes a little
bit longer
thank you bill and thank you chris both
of you for your
presentations today and for this
informative
q a i want to one more time remind our
audience that we did have so many
questions that we were unable to answer
due to time today but they will be
answered via the email address you
provided at the time of registration
i once again want to thank bill kennedy
and chris j grange
for their time today but i want to thank
labrutz and our sponsors akoya
biosciences and cell signaling
technology for underwriting today's
educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
laboratory shortly
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
a survey will now pop up on your screen
your participation
your participation is greatly
appreciated and it helps us
improve improve our webinar program
that's all for now
and we hope to see you again soon have a
great day